Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous avez vu mon écran ?
Depuis quelques temps,
je teste le dark mode.
Mode sombre en français.
Rien de très original.
Vous êtes très nombreux à avoir adopté
ce nouveau mode d'affichage.
Même Google
s'y est mis sur sa page d'accueil
et c'est aussi le mode d'affichage
choisi par défaut de
la plupart des montres connectées.
Enfin, nouveau...
Pas tellement, puisqu'à l'origine
les écrans étaient noirs.
Je m'en souviens.
Alors pourquoi et comment est-on passé
d'une page noire à une page blanche
et vice versa ?
On répond à toutes ces questions
avec un spécialiste
du sujet, Michaël, de la chaîne Micode.
Jamy, je ne t'apprends rien,
si on remonte à la naissance
de l'écriture,
3000 ans avant notre ère,
jusqu'à l'invention de l'imprimerie
en 1450.
On constate que les Hommes
ont toujours écrit sur des fonds clairs.
Alors quand, en 1977,
les premiers ordinateurs personnels,
avec écran intégré,
proposent des fonds d'écran tout noir,
c'est une petite révolution.
Les concepteurs veulent-ils impressionner leurs copains
avec un style dark de hacker ?
C'est peu probable, car à l'époque,
les hackers, ça n'existe pas.
Non, la réalité est beaucoup plus simple.
Techniquement,
on ne savait pas faire autrement.
En effet, dans les années 1970,
il n'est pas encore
question d'écrans plats LCD 4K
à 16 millions de couleurs.
Les écrans d'ordinateur
sont équipés de tubes cathodiques.
Leur fonctionnement est très simple
un signal électrique
envoie un faisceau d'électrons à haute
vitesse
sur un écran phosphorescent.
Lorsque le phosphore de l'écran
est frappé par un électron,
il est excité et c'est
ainsi qu'il produit de la lumière.
Pour des raisons de coût.
La couche phosphorescente
des premiers écrans cathodiques
était verte,
ce qui nous donnait du texte vert
sur un fond tout noir.
Ça rappelle sans doute de bons souvenirs
aux plus anciens d'entre vous.
Le mode sombre est donc la norme et faute
d'autre chose,
personne ne songe à s'en plaindre.
Mais l'évolution du matériel
va permettre enfin de fabriquer
des ordinateurs en mode clair.
Ils ne tardent pas à envahir le marché,
signant au passage la fin du dark mode.
Tous les professionnels
s'accordent à dire que le mode clair
est la meilleure option
pour le confort des utilisateurs.
C'est du moins l'option
la plus ergonomique
pour que les ordinateurs personnels
soient simples d'utilisation.
On estime en effet qu'ils doivent imiter
les gestes du travail.
On crée des dossiers
pour classer les fichiers,
on envoie des courriers électroniques.
On invente même des corbeilles virtuelles
pour se débarrasser
de tout ce qui encombre notre bureau.
Selon cette logique,
les fabricants estiment qu'il
faut aussi imiter le visuel du papier,
des livres
ou des journaux
avec du texte noir sur fond clair.
Mais ce ne sont pas les seules raisons
qui expliquent
l'avènement des écrans blancs.
Les fabricants d'ordinateurs
vont prendre en compte un autre facteur
l'anatomie de l'œil humain.
Vous savez comment fonctionne notre œil
quand il y a beaucoup de lumière,
La pupille, c'est à dire le petit orifice
situé au centre de l'iris, se ferme
pour éviter qu'il n'entre
trop de lumière et que l'on soit ébloui.
À l'inverse, quand il fait sombre,
elle s'ouvre pour qu'il
en pénètre suffisamment.
La lumière atteint ensuite
la rétine sur laquelle se forme l'image.
Le problème, c'est que dans l'obscurité,
nos pupilles ne savent pas très bien
comment réagir quand survient
un éclat de lumière.
Et nous avons alors du mal
à faire la mise au point.
C'est ce qui se passe.
Vous l'avez sûrement remarqué,
quand on fixe
une étoile dans un ciel noir,
ce n'est pas très net.
Il y a un halo autour de l'étoile.
Le même phénomène se produit
lorsqu'on lit sur un écran noir.
Les lettres blanches réfléchissent
et dispersent la lumière
sur les lettres environnantes et forment
alors
un minuscule halo lumineux
sur l'ensemble du texte.
De fait, la lecture est plus floue
et moins agréable.
Pour mesurer la gêne
que peut causer le mode sombre,
des chercheurs
ont réalisé une expérience en 2013.
Ils ont demandé à deux groupes distincts
d'effectuer des exercices
d'acuité visuelle.
L'un avait comme support un écran sombre,
l'autre un écran clair.
On allait enfin
pouvoir trancher la question
le mode sombre est-il plus adapté
ou moins adapté à la lecture ?
La réponse est très claire
le dark mode, c'est moins bien.
On a en effet observé des performances
significativement meilleures
avec le mode clair, notamment
pour ce qui concerne
la rapidité de lecture.
En outre,
plus les caractères sont petits en taille,
plus le mode clair se distingue
par de meilleurs résultats.
Si je récapitule, ça fait des années
que l'informatique utilise
des écrans à fond clair et c'est à juste titre,
ils nous facilitent les choses.
Et pourtant,
voilà que Google, Apple et quelques autres
nous proposent aujourd'hui des écrans
en mode sombre.
Quelle mouche a
donc piqué les géants de l'informatique ?
Il s'agit à coup sûr d'un effet de mode
popularisé par certaines applications
comme Discord
ou Spotify,
qui utilisent un mode sombre par défaut.
Le noir renverrait aussi
à l'imaginaire du luxe.
La tentation de s'y engouffrer
est donc grande pour les stars d'Internet.
Enfin, ils ont aussi sans doute
cédé face à une idée reçue
qui a la vie dure : le mode sombre
serait plus reposant pour nos yeux.
On l'a vu, c'est complètement faux.
Enfin, c'est faux.
On vous a peut-être pas encore tout dit.
Tout n'est pas blanc ou noir
mon cher Jamy
Loin de là. Le mode sombre présente
en fait
un gros avantage sur le mode clair,
il émet beaucoup moins de lumière
et donc beaucoup moins de lumière bleue.
Or, la lumière bleue des écrans,
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler,
est assez préoccupante
pour notre santé,
notamment
pour la qualité de notre sommeil.
En effet, elle fait croire au cerveau
qu'il fait encore jour,
ce qui bloque la sécrétion de mélatonine,
l'hormone du sommeil.
Donc, de ce point de vue,
le mode sombre
le soir est plutôt recommandé.
Tenez, Netflix
ou Disney+ l'ont très bien
compris en adoptant
un dark mode par défaut sur leur site web.
Les développeurs et les traders
raffolent aussi du mode sombre.
Mais pour une tout autre raison
il fait mieux ressortir les couleurs,
que ce soit celles des graphiques colorés
comme sur l'Apple Watch,
du code informatique,
des courbes de trading
ou même tout simplement
des photos de vacances.
Enfin, et ce n'est pas négligeable,
il permet de faire de sérieuses
économies d'électricité.
Un appareil en mode sombre
peut théoriquement consommer
60% de moins que le mode clair,
surtout depuis l'avènement
des écrans OLED sur les smartphones.
Leur fonctionnement est très simple
l'éclairage de chaque pixel est géré
indépendamment quand un pixel est noir,
il s'éteint donc sur cette page en mode
sombre, à peine un quart de l'écran
est effectivement allumé.
En pratique, je préfère vous prévenir
vous ne gagnez pas 60% de batterie, désolé.
Mais pour un site comme la page
d'accueil de Google qui est consultée
par des millions de personnes
tous les jours,
les économies seront quand même
significatives.
À tel point que pendant des années,
les concurrents de Google
ont utilisé cet argument écologique
pour vanter leurs services
face au géant du Net qui persistait
à garder sa page d'accueil toute blanche.
Au final, je vous conseille
donc d'utiliser le mot de clair
la journée et le mode sombre le soir
et la nuit.
Nos téléphones sont aujourd'hui capables
de faire la bascule tout seul
lorsque la nuit tombe.
Evidemment, c'est aussi
une question de goûts et de couleurs.
Vous faites ce que vous voulez.
De toute façon, moi je suis daltonien.
Mais la prochaine fois,
si vous êtes en plein soleil
et que votre téléphone
est difficilement lisible en mode sombre,
faites le test, passez en mode clair,
vous allez être surpris de la différence.
Merci Michaël pour cet exposé brillant.
Je me permets une toute petite précision,
si vous êtes victimes d'affections
comme la cataracte
ou la photophobie,
une très forte sensibilité à la lumière.
Dans ce cas, utiliser le mode
sombre 24h sur 24 peut vous aider
à réduire votre exposition à la lumière
et vous soulager. Allez !
Merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
C'est le meilleur soutien que vous pouvez
nous apporter.
Et puis, si vous ne voyez pas rouge,
eh bien abonnez-vous,
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et si les nouvelles technologies
vous intéressent,
n'hésitez pas à nous proposer des sujets
en commentaire.
On regardera ça de très près avec Michaël.
À très bientôt.
Chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.